[Musik]
hey ihr lieben heute geht total gesund
bei mir zu ihr wisst ja dass ich mir
überlegt habe ich zeige euch
zwischendurch immer wieder sehr sehr
proteinreiche rezepte die sind besonders
gut geeignet wenn ihr zum beispiel
abnehmen möchte oder wenn ihr einfach
eine gesunde ernährung an den tag legen
möchte damit auch überlegt im januar
doch so ein bisschen mehr aufweist zu
setzen und ich mach jetzt heute richtig
leckere bowle und zwar ist eine ball
einfach ein gemisch aus etwas kohle
halte kohle kohlenhydrathaltige
kreationen brecher und ganz viel gemüse
und einem dressing und das ist sogar
vegan ab wandelbar nochmals info falls
sie vegan seit und meine basis ist heute
kino ihr könnt stadtkino auch balkone
also weizen oder reis also da könnt ihr
euch einfach das nehmen was hier gerade
da habt oder das was er am liebsten mit
familie ist wie gesagt heute quinoa die
werde ich jetzt nach packungsanleitung
darin also in salzwasser und dann sehen
wir uns nach dem gar voran wieder unser
kino ist jetzt fertig gegart und ich
möchte jetzt nicht so heiß in die bol
geben und ja auch noch ein bisschen was
vorzubereiten
daher nehme ich ihn jetzt aus dem topf
und gebe ihn zum abkühlen in eine große
schüssel und danach machen ihr ding
kichererbsen weiter
[Musik]
ich nehme immer ganz gerne kichererbsen
aus der dose dann spart man sich diese
ein weich zeit und die sind dann eben
schon weich und ihr könnt jetzt hier
einfach würzen nach herzenslust ich
persönlich mag ganz gerne paprikapulver
natürlich salz etwas für mini fehlen
darf ist zwiebel granulat das mag ich
auch ganz gerne und unbedingt auch noch
ein bisschen kreuzkümmel dazu geben denn
ansonsten bled ja bilder kichererbsen so
ein bisschen auf und das wirkt daneben
entgegen
[Musik]
so einmal alles schön verrühren und den
ofen habe ich übrigens vorgeheizt auf
220 grad ober und unterhitze und da
kommt jetzt ungefähr 23 25 26 minuten
rein
wir müssen einfach selber ein auge drauf
haben und gern auch immer mal wieder ein
bisschen wenden so und rüsten die
kichererbsen ja gerade vor sich hin im
ofen und ich habe mir gedacht ich nutze
die zeit um euch jetzt mal mein tor wo
zu zeigen wir haben übrigens das erste
mal wohl bei denen und david gegessen
wie kam das er hat gesagt mach doch mal
das waren dressing wolltet ihr macht
doch mal das dressing von denen und
david nah und hamza und ich waren dahin
und dann haben wir nur die ball gesehen
und dachten wir können uns jetzt noch
leckere bowle und die war mega lecker
und die wir auch betroffen wie fandest
du es haben soll danach zwei tage lang
sagt hugo ist nämlich auch so eine
richtige eiweißquelle das hier ist jetzt
rollt hof wo auf kichererbsen base es
gibt ja verschiedene arten von toten
und es ist eben ein veganer
fleischersatz was ich gemacht habe ist
ich habe das ganze eine stunde zuvor in
sojasauce und ganz normale sojasauce
eingelegt damit es schön einzieht wenn
ihr keine zeit habe dann reichen
vielleicht auch nur 20 30 minuten
und jetzt ratet ihr das ganze in etwas
öl in der beschichteten pfanne an den
turbo jetzt vier bis fünf minuten lang
schön anbraten von allen seiten und
danach dem herd ganz ganz dringend
ausschalten denn wenn wir den honig dazu
geben darf er nicht stark erhitzt werden
das ist ja bei honig so und wer jetzt
vegan ist er nimmt einfach agaven
dicksaft also den honig etwas schön
schmelzen lassen und dann paprikapulver
dazugeben ich geb dir ein ganz süßes
paprikapulver dazu und ein bisschen was
scharfes scharf mag ich nicht so gerne
und salz brauchte in der regel nicht das
ist ja schon seit sich genug durch die
sojasauce es gebe ich jetzt einfach
wieder zurück in meine schale und dann
zeige ich euch das joghurt dressing und
dann haben wir alle komponenten fertig
und können die bol anrichten
für unser dressing nimmt jetzt ganz
einfach naturjoghurt oder ihr nehmt die
vegane alternative da geht ja zum
beispiel auch soja joghurt und da gibt
ihr jetzt eine gepresste knoblauchzehe
rein außerdem salz und pfeffer und
natürlich ein bisschen honig für die
süße und um den sie müssen
zu wecken das gibt noch mal so einen
tollen geschmack ein bisschen
limettensaft und wenn ihr kein in die
mitte da habt einfach zitrone und dann
für das und fertig ist das dressing und
es schmeckt mega mega gut und jetzt
haben wir alles vorbereitet das heißt
ich liebe dich ist eine ball also nichts
anderes als eine schüssel und gibt da
alles rein auf dem untergrund der ball
geht ganz einfach das kino oder wenn
jetzt solche burgund oder reiter wie sag
mal blog wirklich kein deutsches sport
ist wichtig dass mein jeder kennt ja
selbst im deutschen raum sagt von der
schaumburger und genau wir beginnen
jetzt damit und dann schichten wir
einfach portionsweise in meine
persönliche ball kommt jetzt natürlich
frische rucola tomaten nämlich gerne
cherrytomaten außerdem radieschen rote
zwiebeln und möhren natürlich unser topo
dem irak vorbereitet haben
awo cato bei der avocado mache ich so da
teile ich ihnen erst mal zwei oder sie
in zwei bis er gesagt und schneide sehen
ganz kannst du schreiben dann natürlich
unsere joghurtdressing die vorbereiteten
kichererbsen und noch mal für etwas mehr
biss cashewkerne und gerne zum schluss
noch ein bisschen sesam man kann sich
natürlich auch immer wieder
joghurtdressing nach neben nachreichen
wer bei der ball ist es generell so man
richtet zwar alles portionsweise an
aber am ende wird sowieso alles
miteinander verrührt und dann komm ich
alles und es schmeckt einfach wunderbar
und citic vor allem ihr könnt das ganze
jetzt natürlich nachmachen und das ist
nur eine idee von tausenden einem ball
kann man total variieren
ich schreibe euch meine ganz genauen
mengenangaben unten in die video
beschreibung wenn euch dieses rezept
gefangen und ihr gerne öfter mal gesunde
rezepte haben möchtet dann schreibt es
in die kommentare hinterlassen auf jeden
fall ein dummchen nach oben um ihr zu
zeigen ob euch das rezept gefallen hat
und dann würde ich auch mal sagen gerne
mehr wert sagt vorschläge alles entsteht
hierdurch ein abo dallas war aber viel
dass ich von euch verlangen
na ja sagt er nicht lang von daher
wünsche ich euch ist noch einen
wunderschönen tag viel freude ihm
nachmachen und bis bald
[Musik]